Die Welt wandelt sich -
auch jene der Winzer.
Für manche Schweizer Weinbauern
steht die Zukunft auf dem Spiel.
In Genf will Damien Mermoud
gegen den Rat seines Vaters
ins Geschäft einsteigen.
Er sagte mir: "Mach was anderes!"
Wer das mit Leidenschaft macht,
opfert leicht
sein ganzes Leben dafür.
Im Lavaux hat Pierre Monachon
den Betrieb
seinem Sohn Basile übergeben.
Mit seinen Kindern zu arbeiten, ist
genauso heikel wie mit seinem Vater.
Jetzt habe ich das Sagen,
aber sicher müssen wir wachsen.
Im Tessin
wird das riesige Weingut Tamborini
nach Generationen
der Männerherrschaft
nun von dieser jungen Frau,
Valentina, geleitet.
Als Frau hat man es
in diesem Metier nicht leicht.
Es ist nach wie vor
eine Männerdomäne.
In Graubünden
strebt Irene Grünenfelder
gegen den Willen ihrer Kinder
das Bio-Zertifikat an.
Es ist einfach Schwachsinn!
Auf dem Weg hoch zum Weingut
denke ich mir immer:
wunderschön, aber stark gefährdet.
Und im Wallis führt Marion Granges
mit aller Kraft
eines der Vorzeigegüter.
Sie ist die Seele
des Weinguts Beudon.
Die Winzerin der Berggipfel,
die einen Nachfolger sucht.
Für diese fünf Winzerinnen und Winzer
ist der Jahresverlauf
voller Ungewissheit.
Vier Jahreszeiten.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Gut. Wir sind fast vollzählig.
Schön.
Habt ihr euch alle bedient?
Kaffee und so?
Sind alle so weit zufrieden?
Wir hatten kein einfaches Jahr.
Aber die Trauben sind jetzt toll.
Das dachte ich schon gestern,
als ich durch die Anlage spazierte.
Wir nehmen uns die roten Trauben
vor, den Pinot Noir.
Das wird ein voller Tag. Es gibt
noch Kleinigkeiten zu erledigen.
Wie es dann weitergeht,
weiss ich noch nicht genau.
Heute, am Vorabend der Lese,
sollten wir
den wunderbaren Moment geniessen.
So ist jeder Erntetag ein Fest.
Das ist ja wie eine Schulreise.
Ernte 2018.
Erster Tag.
Damien übernimmt das Kommando.
Und Luc fährt mit zu den Anlagen.
Passt auf die Finger auf!
Vater Luc
übernimmt vor Ort das Ruder.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
On va manquer de vignes,
ce matin.
Ihr verteilt euch
hier links und rechts.
Und wir nehmen uns mal
diese drei Reihen vor.
Sind es nur drei Reihen?
Sie gehen immerhin bis dort runter.
Wenn wir rechtzeitig fertig werden,
wird uns der Chef
sicher noch etwas zu tun geben,
als krönenden Abschluss.
- Dann lassen wir uns Zeit.
Ich mache dann die vierte.
Gemäss Luc ist Damien der Chef.
Und doch müssen sich Vater und Sohn
absprechen.
Was nicht ganz ohne Spannungen geht.
* Beschauliche Klänge *
In Beudon greifen David und Gayane
ihrer Grossmutter Marion
tatkräftig unter die Arme.
Hast du gesehen? Da ist noch
der ganze Riesling. Schön.
Erster Erntetag. In einem
der steilsten Rebberge des Weinguts.
Da sind Kisten, wunderbar.
Da gibt's keine Ausreden.
Na dann, los geht's!
Zu zweit geht es schneller.
Ich freue mich sehr, die Ernte
machen zu können, gesund zu sein.
Ich habe mir gesagt,
es ist eine Freude.
Das muss ich
in vollen Zügen geniessen.
Ich schneide
unheimlich gerne Trauben ab.
J'aime ca.
Die Herausforderung besteht darin,
bis zum Schluss gesund zu bleiben -
ohne Fehltritte.
Denn seit Jackys Tod ruht die gesam-
te Verantwortung auf ihren Schultern.
Macht dich das
nicht einfach glücklich?
Im Winter kannst du hier
mal mit dem Schlitten runterfahren.
Und dann wieder raufklettern.
Die Reihen wieder hochsteigen,
die Trauben nach oben tragen.
In Beudon wird am Steilhang geerntet.
Manche nennen es auch Extrem-Ernten.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ah, David, da bist du.
On tire?
Ist David das Gegengewicht?
- Ja.
In Graubünden kann Irene auf eine
treue Truppe von Hilfskräften zählen,
die mit den Arbeitsbedingungen
vertraut sind.
In Jenins zählt jede Traube.
Man kann quasi
sehr viel einfach nur abschneiden.
Es hat ein paar einzelne drin.
Solche Sachen müssen natürlich raus.
Dann sind ... hellgrüne darunter,
die man meistens
direkt wegwerfen kann.
Die sind wirklich sehr unreif.
Und dann sind noch solche ...
... Schlappen dabei.
Da kann man meistens die
ganze Traube auf den Boden werfen.
Die Erntehelfer sind instruiert.
Da sie jetzt das Bio-Siegel hat,
möchte sie eine vorbildliche Lese
vorzeigen können.
Luna?
On commence en bas.
Et ... ähm ... ici.
Comme ca on peut ramasser plus.
Die Leute, die kommen,
kenne ich alle.
Sogar die Französinnen. Die waren
schon einige Jahre hier.
Die Slowaken nicht, aber die machten
mir einen sehr guten Eindruck.
Sie arbeiten sehr sauber.
Ich vertraue diesen Leuten absolut.
Und sie machen es auch wirklich gut.
Wenn eine faule drin ist,
einfach entfernen.
Ja, wenn es viele sind,
da und da ein Schnitt,
wenn es in der Mitte ist.
Den Rest lassen.
Schlapp? Meinst du die?
Nein, wenn man sie berührt, sind sie
ganz schlapp. Du wirst es merken.
Die Familie
ist zur Unterstützung gekommen.
Auch Tochter Europa
und natürlich Sohn Johannes,
der eines Tages
den Betreib übernehmen wird.
Johannes und ich sind ein Team.
Er ist auch verantwortlich,
er trägt auch Verantwortung.
Meine Tochter kommt einfach gerne.
Sie ist auch gerne
mit den Leuten hier zusammen.
Trauben ernten war früher schon
und ist jetzt noch wie ein Fest.
Ein kleines Fest.
In Rivaz hat die Lese
bereits Ende August begonnen.
Das gab es vorher noch nie.
Diese 3 ha sind die gebündelte Arbeit
eines ganzen Jahres.
Nach der Dürre ist es nun
an der Zeit, Bilanz zu ziehen.
Die Ernte ist
immer auch mit Stress verbunden.
Die Trauben kommen in den Keller.
Da steckt
eine ganze Geschichte drin -
Einflüsse des Klimas,
der Witterungswechsel.
Da ist einiges passiert.
Das Erzählen dieser Geschichte
gehört auch zur Rolle einer kleinen
Winzereikellerei wie unserer.
Und klar ist die Ernte stressig.
Das ist der Moment, in dem
man als Winzer Geschichte schreibt,
festhält, was sich die ganze Saison
über ereignet hat.
Erster Eintrag: das Erntegewicht.
5. 365.
Es ist die Hälfte der Ernte. Und die
Zahlen fallen nicht wie erhofft aus.
Als Basile
die Leitung des Betriebs übernahm,
entschied er,
auf Herbizide zu verzichten.
Und dieses Jahr, mit diesen
überaus trockenen Bedingungen,
haben die Rebenanlagen gelitten.
Deshalb werden wir keine
durchschnittliche Ernte erzielen.
Wir haben weniger Liter.
Das Jahr 2018
war wirklich sehr schwierig.
Dafür bezahlt er nun den Preis.
Auf Qualität setzen und dabei
seine Entscheidung für Bio-Anbau
in die Waagschale werfen -
wird sich Basiles Strategie
dieses Jahr bezahlt machen?
Bei Tamborini findet die Lese
auf industrielle Weise statt.
Ohne ihren Vater übernimmt Valentina
die Beaufsichtigung.
Dutzende von Arbeitern
durchkämmen die 70 ha.
Ich habe diese Arbeit auch gemacht.
Ich weiss, was es bedeutet.
Als ich abends nach Hause kam,
konnte ich mich kaum noch bewegen.
Um diese grosse logistische
Herausforderung zu meistern,
verlässt sich Valentina
auf die Unterstützung von Pierre,
ihrem Chefagronomen.
Ende Woche, also am Sonntag,
werden wir wohl
85 % der Trauben geerntet haben.
Also bleiben uns noch 15 % der Reben
für nächste Woche.
Die Trauben hängen ziemlich lose.
Aber gut, umso besser.
Das ist der Merlot.
Der ist nun mal so.
Ja, dieses Jahr.
Lieber lose als zu kompakt.
V.a. auch wegen der Fäulnis.
Eine gute Süsse.
Und die Kerne sind schon verholzt.
Ich denke,
wir sind etwa bei 92 °Oechsle.
Ecco, 92 °Oechsle?
- Si.
Hohe Zucker-, Alkohol-
und Konzentrationswerte:
das Markenzeichen
dieses sonnigen Jahrgangs im Tessin.
Wie überall in der Schweiz.
Dieses Jahr haben wir
ein sehr grosses Potenzial,
denn unsere Winzer haben
hervorragende Arbeit geleistet.
Die Trauben sind
von guter Gesundheit und Qualität.
Daher gibt es
nicht viel auszusortieren.
Man muss sie nur anschauen.
Ich betrachte sie,
bewundere sie, nehme mir Zeit.
Heute mag ich nichts übereilen,
will diesen Moment geniessen.
Ich kann dabei
meine Batterien aufladen.
Ich arbeite viel lieber
in der freien Natur als im Büro.
Das macht mich auf Dauer wahnsinnig.
Und es macht den Kopf müde.
Hierbei wird man
vielleicht körperlich etwas müde,
es ist sehr warm, man schwitzt.
Aber es bereitet
unglaublich viel Freude.
* Entspannte Klänge *
In Genf vergehen die Tage.
Damien beaufsichtigt die Lese.
Wo ist Papa? Dort drüben?
Lädt er gerade die Trauben ab?
Vater Luc ist immer dabei
und kümmert sich um die Trauben.
Um meine Freunde zu nerven,
habe ich immer gesagt,
dass ich mit 60
in Rente gehen würde.
Das, was meine Frau und ich
aufgebaut haben,
nach meinem Vater und meinem Onkel,
meinen Grosseltern beiderseits,
ist bei Damien in guten Händen.
Es ist unglaublich,
eine solche Menge zu haben.
Wenn man die Trauben anfasst,
merkt man, wie prall sie sind.
Ja, das spürt man.
- Ja.
Geht auch nichts daneben?
- Nein.
Er steht mir immer mit Erfahrung
und guten Ratschlägen zur Seite.
Ich hoffe, dass er
noch lange dabei sein wird,
die Lese auch noch geniessen kann -
mit etwas Abstand vielleicht.
Um nicht dem ganzen Stress
ausgesetzt zu sein.
Kupplung kaputt?
Mist.
Ich schiebe dich an.
Sonst machen wir den Rest halt so,
und du schiebst einfach.
Klar, so machen wir's.
Auskuppeln. Moment.
Ich muss mal schauen ...
Mist, da ist ein Hebel abgebrochen.
Das sind Pannen,
die man nicht vorhersehen kann.
* Motor stirbt ab. *
Es ist die Kupplungssteuerung.
Damien muss eine Lösung finden -
schnell.
Ohne Traktor kann die Ernte
nicht zum Keller gebracht werden.
Es ist sehr warm, daher
muss zwingend verhindert werden,
dass die Trauben noch vor Ort
zu gären beginnen.
In der ganzen Schweiz
findet die Ernte
unter für den Monat September
tropischen Bedingungen statt.
Wie schützt man die Trauben
vor Temperaturen über 30 °C?
In Beudon vertraut Marion auf
ein System, das Jacky erfunden hat.
Das ist Wasser aus Beudon.
Und das hier
ist Jackys Kühlungssystem.
Das fliesst dann von hier
direkt durch die Pipeline.
Das Ganze ist sehr empfindlich.
Man muss unheimlich aufpassen.
Jemand muss oben stehen
und jemand unten.
Und man muss sicher sein, dass es
wirklich bis ganz runter fliesst.
Denn ist der Most in Beudon
einmal gepresst,
muss er runter ins Tal.
Auf einer Höhe von 800 m,
ohne jegliche Zufahrtswege,
musste eine Erfindung her, die ihren
Ursprung bei den Alpbetrieben hat.
Stopp! Stopp!
Die Weissweine werden hier gepresst.
Und fliessen
die Pipeline runter,
die Jacques 1971 erfunden hat.
Das muss langsam durch, damit
der Schlauch nicht zu voll wird,
sonst läuft es über.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die Lese den Steilhang
runterfliessen lassen,
durch diese Leitung
mit einem Durchmesser von 5 cm.
450 m unterhalb
wird der Traubenmost gesammelt
und schnell,
bevor die Gärung einsetzt,
zu Pierre-Antoine gebracht.
Er ist der Önologe, der für
die Weinherstellung zuständig ist.
Es ist genau eine Zwischengrösse.
Das musst du
wieder anschweissen.
Erst biegen wir ihn zurecht,
dann reparieren wir das,
um noch heute fertig zu werden.
Wenn das hier hält, ist gut.
- Ouais, ouais.
Ouais, ca va pas serrer comme ca,
en fait. - Ouais.
Was meinst du,
wenn du mal einkuppelst?
* Motor läuft. *
Okay, dann fahr mal direkt zu
den Reben. Und ich hole die anderen.
Die Erntearbeit
kann fortgesetzt werden.
Aber auf Damien
kommt schon das nächste Problem zu.
* Sie sprechen unverständlich. *
Das Etikett in der Handfläche,
bitte!
Wieso, soll man es verstecken?
Kennst du die Geschichte mit
dem Etikett in der Handfläche nicht?
Du bist doch Sommelier.
Du bist vielleicht der Winzer,
aber überlass meinen Beruf mir.
Wenn alle den Wein mit dem Etikett
nach oben in die Hand nehmen,
bildet sich der Satz
immer auf dieser Seite.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
In Rivaz kommt es zwischen Vater
und Sohn ebenfalls zu Diskussionen.
Als Basile den Betrieb übernahm,
beschloss Pierre,
sich zurückzuziehen.
Es ist nicht immer leicht,
dabei zu bleiben,
v.a. nicht während des Erntestresses.
Das hier wurde bereits gekeltert.
Ich mischte heute Morgen
die Hefe bei.
Das da wird morgen früh gekeltert.
Und der Trester kommt hierhin.
Er ist oft im Weinkeller.
Ich kann ihm in Sachen Druck-
verhältnisse, Mengen, Gewicht usw.
vollends vertrauen. Falls man
eingreifen muss, tut er das.
Er kann gar nicht anders.
Und das ist auch richtig so.
Als er noch der Chef war,
galt nur seine Meinung.
Jetzt habe eigentlich ich das Sagen.
Aber sicher
gibt es manchmal auch Diskussionen.
Hast du die Kühlung ausgeschaltet?
Hier läuft sie nicht.
Okay.
Früher lief manchmal
die Kühlung über Nacht.
Morgens blieb alles zu lange kalt.
Die Gärung konnte nicht einsetzen.
Das ist dann eine Katastrophe.
Daher ist sie hier aus.
Ich habe das jeweils aufgewärmt.
Das machen wir hier nicht. Aber so
wird es nicht aus Versehen zu kalt.
Aber man kann es aufwärmen,
wenn du willst.
Nein, das ist nicht nötig.
* Sanfte Klänge *
In Jenins sind alle Rotweine
unter Dach und Fach.
Johannes unterstützt Irene
tatkräftig.
Die Trauben sind vergärt. Und so
kann nun das Abpressen beginnen.
So.
Der Erste dieses Jahr. Wow.
Vor Oktober.
Es ist einer von vielen Höhepunkten.
Es macht Spass, wenn man ...
... weiss:
"Wow, der erste Wein 2018."
Eine halbe Woche erntet man,
dann ist alles weg,
wofür man ein Jahr lang
gearbeitet hat.
Dann dauert es noch zwei Wochen,
bis man den ersten Wein hat.
Nach dem Abpressen
kommt die erste Degustation.
Das neue Produkt probieren,
die Früchte der Arbeit
eines ganzen Jahres kosten.
Ich würde ihn nehmen.
Irene teilt diesen wertvollen Moment
mit ihrem Sohn.
Johannes arbeitet nun
im zweiten Jahr im Keller mit.
Deshalb
geht es bereits Hand in Hand.
Er kennt jeden Ablauf und Handgriff
und ...
Und?
Kann man nehmen.
Der hat auch eine gewisse Süsse.
Hinten raus ... - Wir haben wohl
den Zucker von dem hier nachgezogen.
Es ist schön, nicht mehr für alles
alleine verantwortlich zu sein.
Das nimmt enorm viel Druck weg.
Denn man hat
jeweils eine Zweitmeinung.
Und nicht irgendeine,
sondern eine qualifizierte.
Das ist sehr wertvoll.
Das ist Johanniter, würde ich sagen.
Johanniter
in einem Inox-Gärbehälter.
Vivi!
- Vivi!
Als ich 16 war,
konnte ich
noch nicht wirklich degustieren.
Klar, ich kannte den Wein,
aber es interessierte mich nicht so.
Der ist sehr aromatisch.
Zumindest im Mund.
Der ist erst im Kommen.
- Er hat eine unglaubliche Süsse.
Mein Vater hat mir
diese Leidenschaft vermittelt.
Ah!
Er ist sehr frisch, oder?
Eine schöne Säure, auf jeden Fall.
Hier in diesen Fässern
lagert mein Vivi.
Dann wollte ich
noch zwei weitere Weine kreieren,
einen roten und einen weissen.
Die Weinfamilie
Valentina Wine Collection
wird ein eigenes Logo haben.
Darauf wird ein Phönix
abgebildet sein.
Ein Symbol für mein Leben: aus der
Asche auferstehen, immer wieder.
Gerade trifft sich Valentina
zwei Stockwerke weiter oben
mit den Grafikern.
Sie legen ihr
einen ersten Entwurf vor.
Wir haben
zwei Entwürfe für dein Label.
Dabei sind wir deinem Wunsch folgend
von einem Phönix ausgegangen.
Ich bin ergriffen.
Zum Konzept:
Wir wollten mit Flügeln arbeiten,
die auch
das Element der Sonne aufgreifen,
weil du eine strahlende, starke
junge Frau voller Energie bist.
D.h. ganz klar weiblich, aber stark.
Dieses Logo stellt genau das dar.
Fico!
Valentina ist sprachlos.
Damien scheint auch entschlossen,
seinen eigenen Weg zu gehen.
Während der Ernte ist es
zu Auseinandersetzungen gekommen.
Ich habe evtl. etwas gesagt,
das ihm nicht gepasst hat.
Nun ist er weg.
Wir sprechen nicht mehr miteinander.
Können wir die Aligote aufbrauchen?
- Warum auch nicht?
Damien möchte die doch verkaufen.
Schon, aber das ist immer noch mein
Haus. Also kann ich das entscheiden.
Es geht nicht darum, was er
alles für mich, für uns getan hat.
Dafür bin ich
ihm unglaublich dankbar.
Aber unsere Beziehung
war doch auch schwierig.
Vielleicht musste es ja so kommen,
damit er wirklich ganz aufhört -
mit einem Paukenschlag.
Hallo, meine Kleine.
Schau, die Trauben sind hier drin.
Mit der grossen Maschine
haben wir den Saft ausgepresst.
Und da fliesst er raus.
Und wohin?
Damien wollte eine saubere Trennung.
Ich konnte das nicht verstehen.
Bei meinem Vater und mir
war das damals anders.
Heute verstehe ich,
dass ich mich aufgedrängt habe.
Ich habe mich mit meinem Vater
mehr gestritten als mit meinem Sohn.
Aber das gehört wohl dazu.
Bei den Mermouds sind lautstarke
Diskussionen Teil des Erbes.
... je ne suis pas sur que, maman,
elle soit a la maison.
Es ist normal,
dass dieser Übergang stattfindet.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Tu veux gouter?
Mmh.
Un petit peu, pas trop, hein.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Il faut verser un verre a ton papa.
In Rivaz hat Basile
immer noch alle Hände voll zu tun,
während Pierre
die Traditionen aufrechterhält.
Gut, wie immer werden
mein Bruder Jean-Jacques und ich
euch ein Lied vortragen.
Wir singen für euch
"Sur la vigne de chez nous",
geschrieben vom
bekannten Chansonnier und Dichter
Jean Villard Gilles,
der in Saint-Saphorin wohnte.
# Autrefois, dans les temps antiques
# y avait au bord du bleu Leman de
la terre nue, des rocs, des champs
# et des forets melancoliques.
# Et puis des braves types
un peu froids
# Qui n'etaient pas encore vaudois.
(Alle) # Entends-tu le glou-glou
dans les verres?
# La servante n'est pas severe.
# Vive la vigne de chez nous!
# Mais voila
qu'en sept mois a peine,
# on voit des milliers de fruits
d'or dont le jus, sacre nom de sort,
# coule a pleins bords
des cuves pleines.
# Pour conjurer ce grand fleau
on le canalise en tonneaux.
(Alle) # Entends-tu le glou-glou
dans les verres?
# La servante n'est pas severe.
# Vive la vigne de chez nous!
* Sanfte Klänge *
In Beudon
herrscht noch keine Feststimmung.
Im Gegenteil.
Ich wollte nur etwas holen und schon
bin ich von der Leiter gefallen.
Das ist das Letzte,
woran ich mich erinnere.
Der Ellenbogen war ausgerenkt.
Und sie stellten fest, dass
meine Nase irgendwie gebrochen war.
Und ich habe das
bis heute noch nicht verstanden,
aber bei der Augenhöhle war etwas
gebrochen und es hat geblutet.
Das mussten sie beobachten.
Und an der Wange
musste etwas genäht werden.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Für Marion gibt es keine Pausen. Sie
hat die Arbeit wieder aufgenommen.
Unterstützt
wird sie von ihren Töchtern.
Das Ende der Ernte naht,
aber die Unsicherheit bleibt.
Dreh das mal, ich schaffe es nicht.
Du musst fest drücken.
Natürlich stellen sich Fragen.
Ob mit oder ohne diesen Unfall.
Die Frage der Nachfolge
stellt sich so oder so.
Was sollen wir tun?
Wir haben ein paar Ideen, aber
kann man die auch alle umsetzen?
Es ist schwierig, das abzuschätzen.
Merci, voila, merci.
(Alle) Sante!
Bravo d'avoir fait les vendages.
Sante, Christine.
- Sante.
Sante, Maria.
Willst du Gürkchen?
Nein, danke,
ich habe schon genug auf dem Teller.
* Sanfte, eindringliche Klänge *
Tous les deux sont du Pinot.
Sante.
A cette nouvelle annee.
- Cheers.
Auf den Abschluss der Lese anstossen,
die Essenz eines Jahres Arbeit
kosten.
Überall in der Schweiz
wird das Ende der Ernte gefeiert.
Zeit, Bilanz zu ziehen
und, in gewissen Betrieben,
die Zukunft auszuloten.
Dieses Jahr
hatte ich wahnsinnig viel Arbeit.
Ich wollte
auch ganz viele Dinge angehen,
und so habe ich mir selber
noch mehr Arbeit gemacht.
Und so geht es voran
mit der Valentina Wine Collection.
Und Vivi 2017 war ein Erfolg.
Bravo, agronomo.
Wie immer trifft Valentinas Vater
erst nach der ganzen Aufregung ein.
Zurück aus dem Urlaub,
voller Worte des Lobes.
Ich muss zuallererst
die Winzer beglückwünschen.
Ihr steht an vorderster Front.
Die Ernte war gut,
gesund und spannend.
Die Lese
war auch perfekt organisiert.
Gesunde, schöne Trauben,
so, wie es sich gehört.
Danke. Bravo, Mattia. Guten Appetit.
Danke.
Salute.
Mein Vater
hat mich immer unterstützt.
Er sagte immer: "Versuch's! Wenn du
hinfällst, steh einfach wieder auf."
Dafür bin ich ihm heute dankbar.
Das hat mich stark gemacht.
Bravo, Luca. Glückwunsch.
Auf das Ende der Ernte.
Zum Wohl.
- Auf den Wein.
Auf den Wein, auf uns,
auf Tamborini.
Ich wünsche mir, dass mein Betrieb
sich weiterentwickelt.
Und eines Tages möchte ich
auch eine Familie gründen.
Denn die Familie ist Quelle
der Freude, der Gelassenheit.
Mal schauen.
Alles in Ordnung?
(Quietschend) Ah!
Uff!
In Jenins liegt die Zukunft
in den Händen von Mutter und Sohn.
Machen wir mal diese Reihe? - Ich
weiss nicht, wie viel es braucht.
Johannes hat da
bereits klare Vorstellungen.
Ich möchte kein grosses Weingut
mit 20 ha werden.
Ich möchte alles selber schaffen
und den Überblick haben.
Ich möchte nicht derjenige sein
müssen, der die Leute delegiert,
sondern mit ihnen arbeiten.
Ich denke,
auch die Kunden schätzen das mehr,
wenn man am Geschmack des Weines
schon fast erkennen kann,
wie der Mensch dahinter ist.
Hart gesagt.
Also, 2018er Wein.
Zum Wohl.
Auf 2019 und die Zukunft.
Wann erfährst du,
ob du nach Neuseeland kannst?
Ende Oktober.
- Wie lange kannst du dort arbeiten?
Ähm ...
Ca. 2 1/2 Monate, haben sie gesagt.
Mehr Arbeit haben sie nicht.
Evtl. findest du eine schöne Neusee-
länderin mit einem riesigen Weingut.
Genau das, was ich will:
ein riesiges Weingut.
Er kann es machen wie Fromm: Zeit-
weise ist er hier, zeitweise unten.
Zweimal pro Jahr Ernte.
Das mache ich sowieso, hoffentlich.
Wir haben es auch schon
angesprochen, die Übernahme,
aber konkret steht noch nichts fest.
Wenn alle Weine eingelagert sind,
möchten wir ein neues Konzept
fürs Abladen realisieren.
Zuerst einmal nähere Geschichten
neu aufgleisen und organisieren.
Irgendwann ist dann
auch mal die Übernahme dran.
Aber das hat noch Zeit.
- Das hat noch Zeit.
Es dauert noch mind. drei Jahre.
Das hängt von dir ab.
- Zwei. Ja.
Bei Johannes
ist erst mal Geduld angesagt.
Sein Weg wird ihn über Neuseeland und
viele zukünftige Erfahrungen führen,
bevor er dann eines Tages
den Familienbetrieb übernimmt.
In Rivaz wird das Ende der Erntezeit
mit einer allerletzten Lese gefeiert.
Die ganze Gruppe zieht los,
um die Trauben
von den steilsten Weinterrassen
des Lavaux einzusammeln,
am sagenumwobenen Dezaley.
Hier, für dich!
Zum Wohl!
* Sie trällert eine Melodie. *
Der ist ja hervorragend!
(Beide)
# Entends-tu le joli glou-glou?
# La servante n'est pas severe.
Vive la vigne de chez nous.
Ist er gut, Jean-Pierre?
Sehr gut, der gibt mir Mut. Danke.
Zurück im Keller prüft Basile
die Früchte von einem Jahr Arbeit.
Er hatte auf Qualität gesetzt.
Eine solche Qualität vorzufinden
ist selten. Das hatten wir 2015.
Aber das hier: einfach unglaublich.
Das wird ein toller Jahrgang.
Wir haben
etwas zu wenig vom Weisswein,
daher haben wir gerade noch
Trauben aus Rivaz dazugekauft.
So vervollständigen wir
unsere eigene Ernte.
Beim Rotwein haben wir
eine schöne Lese dieses Jahr.
Er ist körperreich, süss, konzen-
triert. Es sind Aromen vorhanden.
Da haben wir etwas,
womit wir arbeiten können,
das uns Freude bereitet,
und das ist einfach toll.
Die Rotweine werden prächtig.
Damit kann man arbeiten. Das
freut mich! Wirklich fantastisch.
Ich denke, so ein Jahr
erlebt man nur einmal im Leben.
Basiles Einsatz hat sich ausgezahlt.
* "L'aventurier" von Indochine *
# Egare dans la vallee infernale
le heros s'appelle Bob Morane.
# A la recherche de l'Ombre Jaune le
bandit s'appelle mister Kali Jones.
# Avec l'ami Bill Ballantine
sauve de justesse des crocodiles.
# Bob Morane contre tout chacal,
l'aventurier contre tout guerrier.
Für Damien endet die Ernte im Keller.
Beim Gamay ist die alkoholische
Gärung fast abgeschlossen.
Er kommt zudem noch in die Fässer.
Der wird wunderbar.
Wir wollen aber
keine zu starke Holznote.
Daher nehmen wir dafür
ziemlich alte, zehnjährige Fässer.
Dann wird der Wein
in einen Tank umgefüllt
und kommt anschliessend
direkt in die Flaschen.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit der Arbeit bisher.
Nichts ist schiefgelaufen.
Die Cuvees entwickeln sich gut.
Wir hatten keine Probleme
mit der Reduktion,
keine misslungenen Weine,
keine Fehler unsererseits.
Der Wein reift von selbst.
Ich muss nichts mehr tun.
Alles ist auf gutem Weg.
Ein solches Jahr
ist keineswegs ein Selbstläufer.
Vielmehr zeigt es,
welchen Wert der Bioansatz hat und
dass es möglich ist, so zu arbeiten.
Das gibt Selbstvertrauen
für das nächste Jahr.
Wir können auf dem,
was wir erreicht haben, aufbauen.
Die Erfahrung im Weinbau
ist die Summe aller Fehler,
die man bei vergangenen Jahrgängen
gemacht hat.
Da sammelt sich Wissen an, das einem
Sicherheit für das neue Jahr gibt.
2018 hat Damien die Wende geschafft.
Nun führt er den Betrieb alleine, mit
der eigenen Familie an seiner Seite.
Unten im Tal trifft sich Marion
mit Pierre-Antoine.
Der Önologe stellt schon seit Langem
die Weine Beudons her.
Ein treuer Helfer von Marion -
und seinerzeit auch von Jacky.
Hallo, Pierre-Antoine. Wie geht's?
- Gut, und dir? - Gut.
Ich habe da eine kleine Auswahl
zur Degustation für dich,
denn es hat sich doch einiges getan.
Da bin ich aber neugierig.
- Wirklich spannend.
Das ist er also.
Sehr schön.
Jemand muss ihm ja Leben einhauchen.
Zum Wohl!
Zum Wohl, Pierre-Antoine. Bravo.
- Danke.
Ich hatte das Glück,
dass ich Jacky kennenlernen durfte.
Ich habe ihn sehr geschätzt.
Im biodynamischen Anbau
ist es eher selten,
dass jemand seine Trauben einem
anderen zur Weinherstellung gibt.
Das ehrt mich.
Hier ist doch
einiges an Zucker drin.
Die erste Gärung
ist fast abgeschlossen.
Dann kommt noch die zweite.
Ein weicher Wein.
Ein Hybrid sozusagen.
Witzig, schmeckt wie Limonade.
Mmh.
Beudon und auch Jacky
haben viele im Wallis inspiriert.
Und das muss
auch weitergeführt werden.
Die jungen Generationen
haben aber kein Interesse daran,
den Betrieb zu übernehmen.
Richtig,
die Verantwortung liegt bei mir.
Und dann werden wir sehen.
Sonst suchen wir halt andere Leute,
die sich dafür interessieren.
Sie müssen in der Lage sein,
einen solchen Betrieb zu führen.
Ich will auf keinen Fall,
dass auch nur ein Quadratzentimeter
dieses Weinguts
wieder chemisch behandelt wird.
Dafür haben wir zu viel investiert.
Man schaue sich nur einmal an,
welches Leben in den Böden steckt -
einfach wunderbar.
Und wir haben auch den Beweis dafür.
Bevor ich sterbe,
möchte ich erleben,
wie das ganze Wallis
biodynamisch wird.
Der Weinbau prägt die Täler
in der ganzen Schweiz.
Hinter jedem Rebberg
steht eine Besonderheit,
ein Charakter, eine Weinfamilie.
Eine grosse Vielfalt
an Betrieben und Möglichkeiten.